[Applaudissements]
djamen ce sera sur canal+ à 22h55
mercredi 8 avril jamel est ce qu'on peut
accueillir camille combal
non non mon très bien et bon bah on va
on va quand même on lui donne sa chance
allez allez cali combat est avec nous ce
soir
bonjour bonjour à tous merci en fait je
t'explique camille il m'a appelé il est
en galère dans les transports en commun
c'est pâques et bien non c'est pas
camille 8 levada
m'a pas reconnu je me suis vue on peut
voir la nouvelle note secrète
je me suis rasé sur les côtés tu vois un
peu coup là que je suis le moyen de
choix c'est un peu une coupe d'europe
lorsque je me lance un peu dans le rap
c'est trouver un nom de rappeur
d'ailleurs c'est quoi je vais pas
appeler cave à diam's non je remplace
camille pour le lancement de sa de cette
chronique je sais pas alors comme
d'habitude j'ai surveillé toujours il
fait des trucs un peu comme ça j'ai
surveillé toute la télévision française
aujourd'hui
ouais on va commencer mon petit cyril
quand il faut mais petit sourire alors
partie syrie a commencé tout de suite la
reine en fin de stage que ça vous dirait
un petit enfant de juin s'explique alors
vous savez cela en vaut deux stars je
rappelle le père si le principe est très
simple un petit coup de poing un petit
coup de pompe par la mauricie le
principe est très simple on a retrouvé
deux stars du show biz qui ont fait
l'amour ensemble à retrouver leurs
enfants à la télévision et on l'a
retrouvé dans une émission
pour ce premier enfant de stars on a
appris que valérie benaïm elle aimait
bien le judo si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire quoi la garde tous qui judo
judoka est ce qu'on peut voir les images
la faute et de la petite valoches alpes
est un peu de harry chez ricard est un
peu trop fort je dirais mais nous avons
trouvé l'enfant de valérie bénaïm et de
david douillet voilà c'est c'est un
grand moment de la télévision française
messieurs dames c'est maintenant je suis
un homme de parole
si je vous dis que du fromage sur la
lune vous pouvez me croire
environnementale
allez bon
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait ça je vais te laisser un peu
avec mon coeur il faut que j'ai
malheureusement parce que je dois
remplacer catherine laborde à la
[Rires]
mécanique si vous avez besoin de quoi
que ce soit n'hésitez pas et j'en
profite pour vous dire d'aller voir le
film de djamel de l apc ton truc ça
dépend
[Applaudissements]